esto es un sueño hecho realidad
buenas noches a todos
yo quiero que ser honestos un momentito
nadie los está viendo
pero a los ojos
y quisiera que pensarán en esto
quisiera que pensarán que te atreverías
a hacer hoy si no tuvieras miedo a que
te criticará
que estarías haciendo hoy si no tuvieras
miedo a la crítica
quiero que busques en ese cajón de los
recuerdos si tienes que desengavetar
algo alguna meta algún sueño
pero que tu mente recuerde algo esta
noche que este estuvieras haciendo
si no tuvieras miedo a la crítica
no no yo he dicho que abra los ojos
todavía
bush que busca viendo introduce t
porque hay cosas allí que necesitan ver
la luz
a los ojos alguien pudo ver algo en su
mente pues levanta la mano
fantástico el que no vio nada no se
preocupe ya llegará no se preocupe en
fin
tremendo currículum pero verdaderamente
siento que tengo un expertise
y me siento extremadamente orgullosa por
ser experta en nuevos comienzos en
comenzar de nuevo
he tenido que comenzar de nuevo trabajos
me han votado de uno y renunciando a
otros
he tenido que comenzar de nuevo
matrimonios he tenido que comenzar de
nuevo
embarazos
he pasado noviazgos
y me ha pasado mucho y no sé quizá
ustedes que la noche antes de un gran
gran evento una gran gran presentación
se te borra la presentación y he tenido
que comenzar de nuevo sí o sí quien
conmigo
belleza
también soy perfeccionista recuperación
alguien aquí se quiero ir al club me
escribe después pero me estoy
recuperando la perfección y esto es un
gran gran limitante y vamos hablar un
poquito de eso esta noche pero lo más
importante es que hay dos historias que
quiero traer a la conciencia que me
inspira muchísimo
no sé si reconocen esta silueta pero
este señor hace muchos años atrás tuvo
una gran idea y dijo sabes que yo quiero
tener una empresa de ventas de libros
por internet maravilloso fantástico se
lo contó a su jefe y que dimos un jefe y
yo creo que eso es una muy buena idea
pero para alguien que no tenga un buen
trabajo
de qué estoy hablando
correctamente y esa marca en este
momento es la marca más valorada en el
mundo cuál es la marca
la consumimos por supuesto que les
quiero decir con esto que usted tiene
que fijarse muy bien que usted le cuenta
sus ideas aquí usted le comparte sus
sueños porque puede ser que esa persona
simplemente no esté viendo lo que usted
está viendo y pues sé que usted haga
cine y encabece sus sueños y más nunca
piense en eso sus jefes sus amigos no
son realmente a veces las personas a las
que le tenemos que contar nuestros
sueños
esta persona también no sé si la conocen
de tatón ver está revolucionando el
mundo a su corta edad 16 años y con un
estímulo de enojo está cambiando el
mundo y hay muchas personas que la
critican muchísimas personas que la
odian de hecho a ella le habla a sus
haters ella sufre de asperger y la
tildan de enferma mental a sus 16 años
que les quiero decir con esto que no
importa la edad que tengamos también
podemos recibir críticas eso ya no
importa la crítica no discrimina edad ni
género ni sexo ni ciudad ni nada es más
mientras más sea tu causa mientras más
más grande sea tu visión mientras más
los sietes en tu corazón mayor va a ser
la posición y con eso no te va a decir
que ahora todos nos tenemos que
convertir en
protectores del medio ambiente o ir a
salvar las ballenas no casualmente su
propósito no tiene que ser una cosa
magnánima tú con tu propósito tiene que
ser significativo para ti y solamente
para ti pero a veces no dejamos llevar
el fin porque criticamos
yo tengo una hipótesis y criticamos para
atrás y criticamos
porque es proyectamos nuestra
inseguridad criticamos lo que no
conocemos criticamos lo que nos hace
sentir inseguros criticamos lo que nos
hace sentir incómodos criticamos lo que
pensamos que nosotros no podemos hacer
de hecho ayer estaba pasando por ahí un
comunicado de las vías que se están
cambiando están francisco aquí en el
incómodo
jaja porque porque tenemos que
reorganizar ahora muchas cosas cierto y
empieza la batalla a la crítica a la
crítica a la crítica de algo que puede
realmente mejorar el flujo de muchos
pero criticamos a veces proyectando
nuestras propias inseguridades así que
la próxima vez que alguien les critique
recuerde esto no es usted es la otra
persona
bueno esto soy yo no la canción
no eres bueno cuando alguien le critique
recuerde eso no es usted es la otra
persona es la inseguridad de la otra
persona reflejada en sobre lo que usted
quiere hacer pero qué pasa
como dice el gran aristóteles me encanta
sale una forma de que no te critiquen es
que no hagas nada no seas nadie no digas
nada vale no por supuesto que no y por
qué no
por qué
te quiero regalar un regalo esta noche
un reto esta noche y que tomes una
decisión esta noche porque tú no vista
aquí a pasar desapercibida y te voy a
explicar por qué viniste aquí a liberar
tu sueño y si no te vuelvo a ver más
nunca quiero haberte regalado esto
tú eres un megaevento único del universo
que más nunca se va a volver a repetir
más nunca va a haber alguien como tú
de hecho no hay más nadie va latín y
aunque estuvieras un hermano gemelo más
nunca te vas a volver a repetir si vale
la pena que tengas un sueño grande o
pequeño una misión una meta grande o
pequeña entiende lo que te la dieron a
ti y es tu deber y tu responsabilidad
decidir qué vas a hacer con él
pero eres un evento que más nunca en el
universo se va a repetir así de grande
eres así de importante eres así de
especial eres pero a veces se nos olvida
porque como decía juliette le estamos
metiendo un input a esa software que no
va pero yo hoy quiero que tú liberes un
poquito y hagamos de gauguin por qué no
pero rescatemos un poquito esas
ilusiones esos sueños que necesita
nuestro mundo
la otra cosa es que tú viniste a este
mundo deja tu huella no vista aquí a
pasar desapercibido y si nadie te lo
había dicho antes yo te lo quiero decir
hoy te lo quiero recordar hoy no estaba
aquí de paso no estaba aquí ocupando un
espacio ni un lugar tienes algo que
hacer
y quizás hoy
te estás recordando que es quizás hoy
sea ya la vida ya que estás hablando y
si sientes incomodidad este momento me
alegro porque hay algo dentro de ti que
se está acomodando y hay algo dentro de
ti que quieren hacer pero quizás no lo
has dejado en hacer porque hay muchas
cosas sobre todo esas críticas que
alguien alguna vez te dijo pero que has
dejado entrar a tu corazón pero no hoy
hoy es un día donde liberas y protege
tus sueños porque este mundo necesita
gente más valiente porque este mundo
necesita más bondad más amor si o si
entonces
algo un poquito este ser este ser
misterioso no nada este ser que es como
el protagonista ahora de muchas personas
este ser siempre está de frente el miedo
pero te crees iago del miedo
el miedo lo que quiere es destruir matar
robarte la idea el miedo querer
protagonismo y el problema no es que lo
quiera el problema es que se lo damos
el problema es que le damos demasiada
atención
yo quiero hay que rever se empezó el
miedo que hacerte sentirte pequeñito así
insignificante así que no vales que no
eres suficiente pero le prestamos
demasiada atención hoy quiero reversar
esta ecuación hoy quiero que empieces a
hacer un poquito más sordo de este lado
pero con que me agarró ya el de que me
agarró ya el de aquello que cuando
cerraste los ojos dijiste puedo
atreverme a hacer eso podría estar
haciendo eso de eso quiero que te
agarres esta noche porque cuál es
nuestro mayor miedo yo tengo una
hipótesis
nuestro miedo no es el fracaso ni que
nos vamos a equivocar ni que nos van a
criticar
nuestro mayor miedo según yo está una
hipótesis
es lo brillante y poderoso que sí puede
ser te asusta
tu brillantes como digo yo te asusta tu
poder nos asusta yo me incluyo yo me
incluyo y cuando me hacía la pregunta y
al que estuviera haciendo ahorita mismo
o que te estaría atreviéndose la mitad
mismo si no tuviera miedo a que te
criticarán yo pensé que no me iban a
salir respuestas y salieron respuestas y
salieron respuestas y admiro a gente
como greta atom ver que se puede parar
entre la onu a sus 16 años y decirle a
todo el mundo cómo se siente y hacer que
se enoje la gente a mí me gustaría estar
a veces hasta más directa con amor pero
no tenemos que ser políticamente
correctos y eso es hipocresía y este
mundo necesitan menos de eso necesita
más gente valiente que diga lo que
siente que haga lo que quiera hacer y
deje su huella entonces la crítica para
mí es el precio que pagamos
al querer dejar nuestra marca en el
mundo cuando escoges decir tu opinión
ante una audiencia que de repente no va
a opinar como tú eres valiente aunque
cuando decides alejarte de gente que no
te hace bien eres valiente cuando
decides renunciar al trabajo que no te
está haciendo feliz eres valiente cuando
decía salir del closet
cuando decides meterte al closet eres
valiente hay cosas pequeñitas pararse
aquí contar la historia llorar en frente
de 100 personas grados
necesitamos más de eso
y esta noche si algo te quiero regalar
es que pienses en eso y no corras hacia
el miedo a la crítica sino que corras
hacia los motivos que te hacen soñar en
grande en otra dirección y si algo
tenemos que llevarnos hoy de aquí es
esto
me encanta esta frase porque para mí ha
sido como una bandera los pedros los
pedros los perros ladran sancho señal de
que cabalgamos porque para mí la crítica
es evidencia que me muevo para mí la
crítica es evidencia de que algo estoy
haciendo de que mi vida está haciendo de
un significado para alguien más no es el
resultado de algo mal que estoy haciendo
es la evidencia de que me estoy moviendo
y de verdad si usted ve esta perspectiva
cuando le critiquen es porque usted
estamos viendo la vida de alguien o su
propia vida la gente se siente incómoda
la gente no quiere el cambio pero usted
si usted quiere crecer usted quiere
progresar pero a veces se deja llevar
pero a partir de hoy no
así que el reto de hoy es el siguiente y
me lleva a este cuentito severísimo dos
ramitas tratando de subir un árbol
mucha gente las críticas que locas no
mal que mal no una bonita terminó de
subir porque creo que terminó de subir
se sabe la respuesta por qué
era sorda
la ranita que terminó subiendo era sorda
y hoy quiero quiero invitarte a que
hagas de oídos sordos a todo aquello que
no está alineado a lo que tú quieres
hacer a todo aquello que te atreverías a
estar haciendo si no estuvieras miedo a
que te criticarán así que el que se
presenta por su vida en lo bueno de lo
malo en el verdadero valiente y esto
estás aquí hoy y vas a tomar todo lo que
vamos a escuchar hoy y vas a hacer algo
al respecto sí o sí te quiero contar
esta historia antes de terminar aquí
estoy yo hace 27 años yo bailaba en una
en una
un grupo que se llamaba tiempo conoce
que con mi mejor amiga de la escuela
todavía mi mejor amiga y cuando nos
separamos ella se convirtió en una gran
vendedora puedo decir que es la
vendedora que más yo admiro y a veces
les digo sabes que tú puedes vender
hielo en el ártico a los pingüinos le
encanta
ella sabe vender lo que sea en fin como
todas las cosas un par de años después
que me botaron y tuve que comenzar de
nuevo
decidí emprender y cuando desee
emprender hago esta fiesta invito a mis
amigos invito a otros colegas y cuando
termino yo emocionadísima viene mi amigo
y me dice oye ya me encanta todo te amo
te felicito pero si alguna cosa yo dudo
mucho y no entiendo y no creo que tú
puedas comercializar estos que están
haciendo el coaching
no te veo comercializando el coach y no
lo veo no lo veo por supuesto que
viniendo de ella usted cree que yo me
sentí me sentí que o maldad si ella no
lo ve
mi mejor amiga porque a veces las
críticas vienen de donde el círculo es
de mí
años después gracias a dios muchas
empresas me apoyaron
muchos países me llamaron para
transformar algunas vidas pero este
señor vino a panamá john maxwell traído
por mi mejor amiga
porque ya sabe vender muy bien y se
trata señor y me dice ya que necesito un
talento nacional que le haga el telón a
john maxwell tiene siete minutos para
hablar lo quieres dije ok
cerré el teléfono y casi la llamó para
decirles que no lo quería porque cuando
eres valiente con tu vida te vas a
presentar
en fin hable ante 2000 personas pero fue
mi mejor amiga la que me llamó y hace un
par de meses mi mejor amiga me acompañó
a miami cuando un grupo de latinas me
invitan a hablarles del empoderamiento
femenino y de la marca personal mi mejor
amiga no se quiere perder nada ahora
pero mi mejor amiga tenía razón ella no
sabía como yo voy a comercializar este
nuevo negocio porque ese sueño era mío
donde ella cuando alguien te dice que no
puede te está diciendo que él no puede
así que tiene que tener bien claro que
son sus inseguridades no las tuyas
la decisión gracias si dale dale dale
a pesar de esto todos esos
así que a gente no se trata de ignorar
la crítica se trata de incluirla en la
ecuación así que qué te atrevería a
hacer hoy aún a pesar de que te van a
criticar es la respuesta sea el sueño
que sea que vayas a soñar
resiste la tentación de abandonarlo
resiste la tentación de abandonar tu
sueño por más que te critiquen sueña en
grande y esfuérzate para materializarlo
pero sobre todo mi lema para ti esta
noche es que no dejes de brillar porque
a otros les molesta tu luz muchas
gracias